we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p here is the
egg man who is disgusted disgusted by
what he has been seeing in response to
the Syria bombings on Fox News take a
listen to this watching Sean Hannity and
Oliver North discussed the recent
missile attack in Syria disgusts me it
is disgusting I can't stand them oh it's
all Obama's fault because he said they
didn't have chemical weapons anymore oh
man I can't take it I hate these guys
but hey you know have a good weekend
world of Shalom a very very somber
low-energy egg man I mean clearly
affected by this that is not unless he
has a head cold or something that is not
the egg man's demeanor as we have become
accustomed to it at first I didn't even
believe that was the Eggman that I not
the Eggman that we know and love no no
it is now I mean we still love the
Eggman yet it's not the egg man's
persona that we've come to know and love
him through I guess is what we're saying
yeah it is pretty sickening what we've
been seeing on right-wing media around
this serious stuff it has been sickening
and it's just reminiscent of what we
were seeing before the Iraq war as I've
talked about on today's bonus show New
York made tuition free at public
colleges for the middle class we will
talk about the retail apocalypse and we
have received in the mail from a viewer
very generously vegan chocolates for a
vegan producer Pat Forde and I to try we
will be trying them on the bonus show
Pat is holding up one of the chocolates
is that the truffle I picked the white
one yeah those up better which one which
one is that I never white chocolate
trouble typing we have a whole thing we
should talk about white white chocolate
actually we'll talk about that on the
bonus show so a lots happening on the
bonus show get instant access to the
bonus show by going to david pakman.com
slash membership the coupon code i voted
17 is available please continue making
those pledges on patreon to replace the
lost youtube revenue patreon.com forward
slash david pakman show that is it for
today and we will speak to you on the
bonus show in mere minutes